- All right, I'm bouncing,
I'm gonna give you guys
10 seconds to take a screen
shot to enter the contest.
That was sorta weird.
(man laughing)
("Unanimous" by Ryan Prewett)
♪ Throw your uppercut,
try to hit me in the gut ♪
♪ You're whisperin' my name-- ♪
- Boston, love the people
of Boston, love 'em,
hate the Patriots.
Heading to two client
meetings here in Boston
and then heading to the airport, Logan,
and on our way to Sweden for two days,
with Babin here, which is exciting.
A little takeaway, something
interesting has emerged
over the last couple days.
Three or four people have
called me out for public debates
on subject matters, and I can't figure out
what the debate's about,
other than they're trying to
bait me and goad me into
giving them exposure
for whatever thing they're up to.
Which I weirdly respect in
that 3% gangster kind of thing,
but the truth always wins and
everything's on the record,
and all of this stuff happens publicly.
And your grandkids are
gonna make fun of you
for not doing the right thing.
I don't get it.
I understand if a Patriots
fan here in Boston
wanted to debate me about football,
but people are trying to
debate me about things
that I can't even create
any understanding about
what we're debating other
than they want more followers
from me to jump in.
- [Man] That's it.
- Which is amazing, I
appreciate it, I'm humbled.
But it's tough 'cause I
don't even know who you are.
♪ Look at you tremblin',
step into the lion's den ♪
♪ Bet you wish you'd stay at home ♪
(dinging)
♪ Beggin' for mercy
underneath your breath ♪
♪ When I ain't even sweatin' yet ♪
♪ My leg has been near the storm there ♪
- No.
- Would I expect you to see us together?
- What's your?
- I feel like when I see you together
I go into the black hole.
Where are we going, what are we doing?
- Yeah, I don't know.
- Guys, come on.
(all laughing)
- You were walking. (laughing)
- Come on, Trout, I don't do logistics.
Vlog, this has been well-established,
I don't do logistics.
Babin, that's on you, by the way.
When DRock and Iris are here,
they help me with logistics.
I feel like you just
tag along for the ride.
What do you have to say
for yourself, Babin?
- Just add it to my list of fuck ups.
- Yeah, I don't do logistics.
I don't have to do everything around here.
I try to do everything,
it's not that I'm fancy,
I just don't fuckin' do logistics.
I'm not gonna look at my fuckin' number,
I gave you the fuckin' number.
Nate, you weren't doing shit.
Trout and I actually went
to go get some business.
- I was doing some.
You were just,
you and Babin were sitting
in like a nicely lit lobby
just hanging out.
- [Nate] You know that I need you,
so it looks very nice.
- Okay, I'm interested.
♪ Look at you tremblin' ♪
- Gary.
- Yeah, sure.
♪ Step into the lion's den ♪
- Oh thank you so much.
- You got it, bro.
♪ Bet you wish you'd ♪
♪ Stayed at home ♪
♪ Beggin' for mercy
underneath your breath ♪
♪ When I ain't even-- ♪
- So I've looked under
the hood of this business
quiet a bit, obviously has
different dynamics than,
but I mean, shit, you guys know this.
If you guys care about the five
year macro of the business,
which you may or may not
care about being a human,
as an employee within the organization.
But for legacy purposes
and like, I'm sure you guys
have pride and are good human beings,
your company has to do
real shit in 2018 and 19,
or it gets real vulnerable, real fast.
You guys have to at all
cost, win on long form video
on Facebook, it can fundamentally change
your brand positioning.
You have to become religious about
understanding what that means
with or without us, you have to.
It's the under-priced
attention that can give you
a chance to reframe your brand,
to three to five
different significant sets
at the lowest possible
cost, in lieu of people
wanting to go check out fancy new places.
You're not gonna renovate
your entire place,
you know what I mean?
You're not gonna deploy the capital,
so they're gonna get real consideration,
just 'cause it's new.
You guys have to
disproportionately story tell,
you have to be 150 index,
not to take a big punch
in the mouth, so you better start fast.
- [Man] You can get some screen talk.
- [Man] Yeah, I really need
you to keep a copy of that.
I've haven't been traveling with him
that much recently so--
- What happened, am I losing a viewer?
- What?
- [Gary] Am I losing a viewer in your mom
'cause you're not on as much?
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
- Mama Schroeder, I promise you,
I will use Nate in more content,
'cause I'll do anything for ratings.
- (laughing) Let's go.
- Babin, no joke, that let's go--
- Let's go.
- I want you to re, I want,
send it to your clip it,
that will be in it, that little let's go,
I literally want that Nate let's go clip
to pop up randomly--
- Let's go.
- For like 11 straight vlogs in a row.
(Babin laughing)
Where it makes no sense, got it?
You'll pass that on to the team?
Good for you.
Well listen, you should go tend to that.
I have two really amazing,
two incredible women
that I work with, one from, one from,
who both reached out to
me as a mentor of like,
should I go do this, should I go do that.
And when I emailed you the other day,
I was in the second of those
two meetings in two days,
and I said, wait a minute, I remembered,
I kinda recalled from our call.
So I'd like to introduce you to them.
One is named, she was at,
now she's been in five years,
amazing, senior, kind
of like a real player.
And the other one is,
name is, she's younger.
Good, okay, well listen, it's a home run.
These two women are
gonna be winners in life,
they'd be blessed to
spend an hour with you,
half an hour with you, so do you want me
to do that on email or text?
You're not gonna be able to
use a lot of that content,
beep the shit out of it, but
I'm just introducing people
and it's gonna be wins for them and,
I'm not lookin' for anything in return.
Karma points to the fuckin' max.
Sure, in 19 years, could one
of them give me business?
Sure, more likely, in
16 years can one of them
take an hour meeting with Misha
'cause she wants to learn
something from them, probably.
But more importantly, the
fuckin' world doesn't lie.
You know there's a great
thing in basketball,
it says, ball don't lie.
You know, when there's a bullshit foul
and then the guy misses both free throws
and you're like, ball don't lie.
Rasheed Wallace used to always say,
I feel like world don't lie.
You do the right thing,
shit works out at the end.
I play under the fuckin'
thesis of world don't lie.
Just a, how long was that?
I'm gonna actually give you an exam,
I love it, this is gonna be a great clip.
How long was that goddamn call?
That call was two minutes.
In two minutes, one of the biggest CEOs
in the world, top 500 companies,
I'm introducing two young talents to them,
it's just gonna be a win.
I'm now out of the equation, two minutes
doing good love for three people.
Two people meeting one person separately,
who knows what happens
but world don't lie.
Do the right thing, expect
nothing in return and just,
in 19 years, six years,
four months from now.
I'm in some place, they're
like oh wanna do that.
By the way, let me tell
you why I wanna do that.
You did, da-da-da, fuckin'
do the right thing,
everybody's worried about themselves.
Best way to worry about yourselves
is to do for other people.
I know this sounds something like,
religious joint, fine.
And not reading the Bible
and knowing that stuff,
I don't know, but I promise you this.
It's practical as fuck, world don't lie.
Instagram, Instagram,
Instagram, Instagram, what up?
Big ups to all 1,700s of
you, damn that's crazy.
- That's so fast, Jesus.
- 2000 people in like
four seconds.
Bitcoin, you know, bought
my bitcoin in 2014,
have played with it a little bit.
Think there's so many
more experts than me,
hence why I haven't talked about it.
It's good to put this
in the vlog, actually.
The reason I haven't gotten
deep on cryptocurrency,
blockchain, ethereum, bitcoin, litecoin,
is I don't feel like I
know as much as most people
and I don't like to talk about shit
when I don't know as much as other people.
I think there's better sources.
I have intuitions, I'm
marinading, I'm back at the lab,
a.k.a. my head, right now
trying to get educated.
Whether it's voice, whether
it's cryptocurrency,
whether it's a couple other things,
small business, marketing,
by the way, is a weird one.
I'm gonna take late
December, early January
to walk the beach a little bit and think.
And I'm gonna come out
guns a fuckin' blazing
like I always do in January,
and I promise you vlog,
promise you Instagram live, I will bring
straight fuckin' thunder
and pound it down your mouth
for free, when I get to it.
If you go straight and then right,
like kinda back on the highway,
or if I kept goin' straight, right?
- [Driver] Yeah I think if we
kept goin' straight--
- Yeah if we kept straight yep
take a right, right, yeah.
- [Driver] We can then come
up here on parallel street.
Beacon is comin' up, so I'm
assuming Com Ave is right.
Parallel to it.
- That's so funny, oh good job, Babin.
In my old stomping grounds, '94 to '98,
Gary V is a very different character.
Yeah, I know this area super well.
This is the train station, right.
- [Driver] Yeah it is, yeah.
- Oh, that's exactly right.
- [Driver] Beacon right there, Com Avenue.
- God I haven't been here in awhile.
Boy do I love Mass, and
do I hate the Patriots.
What an interesting like--
- [Man In Backseat] You
have a lot of excuses.
- I really do weirdly enough,
people don't even know.
But I love Boston,
and I really hate the
New England Patriots.
- [Man In Backseat]
How'd you find Mount Ida?
- They sent me a postcard in
the mail, I filled it out.
- [Man In Back Seat] Is that real?
Direct mail, it worked--
- Direct mail, it works. (laughing)
That's amazing actually,
the fact that I literally
picked my college on direct mail.
The target musta been like
bottom 1% rank in the class.
They literally--
- They had no insights to go off of.
- I feel like they were like,
the segmentation was like,
ridiculously punted school
for the last decade.
(upbeat, bouncy music)
What's that?
(cameraman muffled)
- Yeah, that's nice, let's do it.
- [Man] Never before.
- [Man With Camera] Cool.
- It was an honor, man.
Take care of yourself.
Built his own garages, you know.
Learned a lot, right?
It's so crazy.
Nate, I tell you so much, right.
- Probably.
- But what do you really think?
It is kinda weird, right?
I like it, it's super cool.
It's super interesting.
Hey everybody, it is your favorite time.
Every vlog, that was a quick transition,
every time, the greatest superhero ever
has made his way to Boston.
Look at that shot.
Hold on, let me see this.
Hold on, I feel like I'm now good at this.
That shot's nice, right?
- [Babin] Very nice.
- [Gary] But how do you zoom in?
Oh I got it, I got it, don't,
don't touch.
- There you go.
Fair enough.
- This is nice.
Boston, good job, all right, here you go.
Favorite superhero ever,
by the way, I can't wait.
You think I sold a lot of sneakers, Nate?
You think there was a lot of K-Swiss sold?
When the action figure comes out--
- [Nate] We got an action figure?
- I think the Airport Gary action figure
Hasbro, Mattel, call me.
I think the action figure is real.
I'm telling you, the comments
are gonna roll in right now.
I think the action figure,
it is your favorite time
folks, I am headed to Sweden.
The greatest superhero
that you've ever seen
is now coming to be Airport Gary.
- Yeah I mean, that's
such a good question.
Good job, Babin, that's
something I don't see
Iris or DRock asking, a
little deeper explanation
for the origins of one of the
great superheros of all time.
Spiderman was bit by a spider,
Superman the metro thing,
I need to get cozy.
You know the key in airports for me
is it's like my home, I
get cozy, I get work done.
I get in that kind of like,
I'm like one with the airport.
And so I have to get real cozy.
Oh wait a minute, look at this, Babin.
We have like the same hat.
- I'm like Airport Tyler
all the time though.
- Oh you mean you're Airport Tyler
in real life at all times.
- Basically.
- But I have to wear other clothes
'cause I do something for a living.
- Exactly, that's it.
- I gotta get one with the airport.
So in this gear, I get real
cozy, I feel real calm,
I can just get my work done.
So, heading to Sweden,
looking forward to it.
Stockholm, stand up.
(smooth, upbeat music)